thank you for that it's my pleasure
how you doing great yeah great
life is good yeah you have are you
looking forward to the holidays you got
uh thanksgiving plans what are you gonna
do
eat just eat i'm not on tour anymore e
now when you're on tour you got to lose
the weight what's the idea or you can
just go
you know get in those pants
they could let the pants out a little
bit right no that would be
affecting your ego a little bit okay now
see it's all about the tag inside there
right so i've had them even stitch
smaller sizes tags inside
just to get away with it sure so what do
you do do you get down to some serious
eating
on thanksgiving you just eat a whole
turkey yourself what do you eat too much
then uh sit there go and then you know
and [ __ ] about being bloated and stuff
and then find yourself
kind of drifting back toward the kitchen
again and right that kind of stuff
yeah that sounds very good andy's gonna
have a tub full of turkey over his house
if you wanna stop by
your sister gonna be there
this girl rocks yeah she'll she will
have calmed down by then
uh you know what i want to ask you about
i love it's judgment day [ __ ]
sorry i'm sorry that
let's talk about the uh something that
would freak me out is that you have
these
these garth tribute bands that are out
there and i know that's very flattering
to you
but what's it like when you come face to
face with these people who are supposed
to look like you they've sort of devoted
their life to being garth brooks
well you sometimes wonder you know when
the guys they're all sweet too but
you know when they're when they're 700
pounds and you're like
damn do i look like that on tv you know
and mm-hmm and then
uh or you know if you're out signing the
lady says when you sign us for my
boyfriend he looks exactly like you it's
like
well tell him hi i said well you can
tell him he's right here it's like
this guy looks like a small volkswagen
you know it's like
geez do i how do i look on tv so so i
mean it's but it's sweet that they do
that i mean
it's it's very nice it's just it's a
weird feeling i've sometimes had people
come up to me and go like
you know my friend looks so much he
looks exactly like you
everyone says he looks exactly like
conan o'brien come on over here rodney
[Applause]
oh my god i
met him i met him down the lobby i
thought that was you
[Applause]
did people know garth that was me i was
saying hello
here's garth i'll say hi before the show
hi how are you
i mean do people know you're like six
six or whatever people don't know that
no from tv
we've lowered the chair right i have the
voice of an 11 year old boy
so people always expect me to be about
five five
in reality i'm well over eight feet high
uh we have to talk about this new album
because one of the things you've done
is uh which i think makes it more fun
for people out there buying it
makes it more of a collector's item is
you have six
different covers is that right yes six
totally different packages
uh with the tour with each million
ticket we did a celebration so
with the live album it shipped about six
million so we put six different packages
covering milestones in our career
the one you've got there's central park
but we also did the croak park one in
ireland the texas stadium we got a bunch
of them right here let's take a look
we'll just scroll through the six covers
be
there's one right there it's texas
stadium there's another one
in dublin we got another one world tour
two right we got another one
that was um what's that all about what's
that one about
[Laughter]
we got another one here let's take a
look i'm just curious those are nice
i didn't realize don knotts was such an
influence
and then finally we wrapped it up with
andy's favorite person
i like that one that's that's those are
gonna smell like hot cakes
that's uh so
uh you also have a special contest
what's the contest
oh it's just uh this tour has been the
people's tour they picked where the
cities were how many nights in each city
how long the shows were
so we decided to let them pick where the
tour ends and so anywhere that garth
brooks double live album is
you can register to win garth live in
your backyard then we'll uh have the
drawing in january and see
if and where you know where we go what
if someone the person who wins has like
a tiny apartment
what do you do what do you do when a
couple hundred thousand people show up
well it's just
it's just make room you know we'll have
fun mm-hmm we're gonna if i mean and if
it is in a small town somewhere and they
let us move down to their football field
or something
you got to get the mayor's permission
and it's going to but it's going to be
fun they can make it as large or small
as they want
sounds like a good time and you you also
uh you do something that's kind of
i find it a little unusual but you take
very seriously what you do i guess
you're very appreciative so you go
is this right you go to the factories
where they make the cds
is that right to meet the workers there
well you go there to uh to tell them
thanks because a lot of times they'll
they'll spend their weekend especially
since it's around the holidays
a lot of times like on the hits they
gave up their thanksgiving weekend to do
that for us so you go there try and tell
them thanks and
and you know see if you can lift
anything for free
that's nice you made me actually feel
bad when i read that i thought
am i supposed to be going to where they
make the tvs
because i haven't done that you might
try that yeah
that would not help uh and then before
we go i wanted to ask you about
you your daughter's name which i i
didn't know this but
you you named your daughter it's an
unusual name it's an interesting name
it's very nice but
it it it shows the different influences
that you've had in your life is that
right you talking about the oldest one
taylor
yeah what's her name taylor main pearl
taylor main pearl
brooks yeah the brooks thing was a gimme
but
you weren't up all night thinking of
that part i got the last part
uh taylor was for james james taylor
yeah he's huge
musical influence in my life um
pearl is for mini pearl sandy wanted
that real because her many were real
close
and then maine was um where taylor was
uh
um where the idea came to actually
yeah that's against the law in maine you
know
that's why we got out there that's a
nice idea though my daughter's name and
when i have a daughter it will be elvis
manhattan hill
elvis i live here in manhattan and benny
hill
is the guy for you isn't it obvious yeah
i'm telling you
you know i've noticed i've never seen
you two guys in the same room at one
time
me and benny hill yeah i'm just a
reincarnated version uh the garth brooks
uh double live
uh album is in stores right now and
you're performing at the christmas in
rockefeller center
uh that that's a uh a special is that
right the christmas tree
sounds fun wednesday december 2nd at 8
o'clock p.m
right here on nbc and uh you're going to
take a little break right now and then
you're coming back later in the show
you're going to
you're going to perform for cool yeah i
would like to i think we can work that
out yeah
thank you very much we really appreciate
it dark brooks everyone
dave foley coming up we'll be right back